[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo Leute kleine Warnung heute wird es
makaba heute wirds sehr mahaber ja aber
so richtig herzlich willkommen zu einer
ganz besonderen soap opera eine
Seifenoper im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
um genauer zu sein einer italienischen
Seifenoper und wie es sich für eine
ordentliche italienische Oper gehört mit
jeder Menge Tragik und natürlich Seife
und Schokokeksen aber keine veganen
definitiv nicht
also wobei ich mir jetzt nicht ganz
sicher bin ob Schokokekse wirklich so
ein typisches Thema für italienische
Opern sind da war ich zu wenig in
italienischen Opern ja ich glaube da
geht es ihrem Sachen wie Liebe Tod
Schicksal während davon haben wir heute
auf alle Fälle jede Menge und eine
Opernsängerin die ist auch am Start aber
keine Sorge sie wird nicht singen und
wir auch nicht ja sie wird leider
sterben und nicht nur sie
genug gespoilert wir fangen mal an ich
bin Toni Heyer und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
hallo wir erzählen euch heute die
Geschichte von Leonardo chiantioli habt
ihr was zum Knabbern bereit sehr gut
dann stellt es besser jetzt mal zur
Seite denn das ist keine Story die man
beim Essen hören will vorab noch ein
Hinweis wir haben die Geschichte
gründlich recherchiert aber viele
Details insbesondere der
Lebensgeschichte von Leonarda die sind
unklar oder werden widersprüchlich
erzählt eine der wichtigsten Quellen ist
außerdem ihre Autobiografie und dass die
wirklich objektiv ist das kann man dann
doch bezweifeln aber zumindest leonardas
taten die sind gut dokumentiert
1893 montella Italien
Mariano cancchioli ist verliebt
unglücklich verliebt seine Angebetete
Emilia Marano zeigt ihm die kalte
Schulter doch canculi ist nicht bereit
diese Zurückweisung hinzunehmen er will
sich holen was er nicht haben kann er
will sich rächen er will seine
vermeintlich gekränkte Ehre
wiederherstellen und
vergewaltigt die junge Frau
Emilia ist jung und unerfahren und nach
allem was wir wissen eine unschuldige
und ahnungslose Seele sie begreift nicht
was ihr widerfahren ist doch sie ahnt
dass es eine Sünde war möglicherweise
Ihre eigene trägt sie nicht als Frau den
Makel der Erbsünde ist nicht die Frau
immer schuld ist sie es nicht die den
Mann zur Sünde verführt okay hier nicht
vergessen wir befinden uns im streng
katholischen Italien das ausgehenden 19
Jahrhundert
da ist niemand an den sie sich wenden
könnte niemand der ihr sagen würde du
hast nicht den Hauch einer Schuld du
bist das Opfer eines Verbrechens und der
einzige der dafür verantwortlich ist das
ist der Vergewaltiger der Täter aber
Emilia schweigt doch als ihr Bauch zu
wachsen beginnt stellt ihre Familie sie
zur Rede und die nun eindeutig
Schwangere Emilia erzählt die ganze
Geschichte die Familie beschließt den
Täter zur Verantwortung zu ziehen
klingt erstmal gut aber sie verstehen
darunter etwas anderes als man heute
denken würde ja denn sie zwingen Mariano
und Emilia zur Heirat das Mädchen muss
also ihren Vergewaltiger heiraten und
der geht nicht nur straffrei aus nee er
bekommt auch noch die Frau auf die er
ist sowieso abgesehen hatte und das ist
einfach ekelhaft aber genauso kommt es
leider die beiden heiraten und am 18
april 1894 wird das Mädchen geboren
Leonarda Emilia hasst ihre Tochter vom
ersten Tag an sie kann ihr nicht
vergeben was Mariano canjuli ihr angetan
hat eins ist klar Leonarda wird keine
glückliche Kindheit haben absolut nicht
zweimal versucht Leonarda sich das Leben
zu nehmen das erste mal da ist sie
gerade 13 Jahre alt sie überlebt beide
Male erst mit 23 Jahren scheint sich ihr
Leben zum Besseren zu wenden
Leonarda ist verliebt
1917 heiratet sie raphaele panzardi
raphaele ist beim Grundbuchamt der Stadt
angestellt ein kleiner Beamter nicht
gerade eine gute Partie so sieht es
zumindest ihre Mutter und verflucht die
er und ihre Tochter ein Leben in Leid
soll sie führen ich sag mal so
ihre Mutter hat bisher schon alles getan
um diesen Fluch wahr werden zu lassen
aber für Leonarda ist das noch mal eine
ordentliche Schippe oben drauf denn sie
ist tiefgläubig und tief abergläubisch
und so ein Fluch noch dazu von der
eigenen Mutter das ist schon echt eine
große Nummer das nimmt man nicht so
einfach auf die leichte Schulter auf
keinen Fall wobei es an der Stelle
vielleicht noch mal ganz gutes darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir hier auf leonardas
eigene Aussagen in ihrer Autobiographie
angewiesen sind es ist nicht
auszuschließen dass sie diese ganze
Sache mit dem Aberglauben vielleicht
auch als Entschuldigung vorgeschoben hat
ich denke hier können wir ihr schon
Vertrauen das war damals nun weiß Gott
nichts Ungewöhnliches
Leonardo geht irgendwann in dieser Zeit
auch zu einer Wahrsagerin und die
verspricht ihr ein langes Leben ist doch
gut voller Leiden
ja nicht gut und dass sie im Gefängnis
und in der Psychiatrie landen würde
absolut gar nicht gut aber auch dass sie
viele Kinder haben würde das wiederum
ist sehr gut Leonardo wünscht sich eine
große Familie und dass sie all ihre
Kinder überleben und zu Grabe tragen
wird
okay Stopp stell dir vor du machst ein
Glückskeks auf und auf dem Zettel steht
sowas also wenn ich mir aus der Hand
lesen lasse oder so dann will ich
gefälligst hören dass alles gut wird und
nicht ein super tolles Leben vor mir
habe naja ich denke mal das wollte
Leonarda sicher auch aber im Gegensatz
zu dir glaubt sie an Wahrsagerei und
Flüche und all den möglichen Hokus Pokus
und deshalb muss sie das wirklich schwer
getroffen haben ja zumal es so aussieht
als würde der Fluch der Mutter wirken
und als hätte die Wahrsagerin die
Wahrheit gesagt drei Kinder werden tot
geboren zehn sterben noch im Säuglings
oder Kleinkind Alter warte 10 Kinder
insgesamt wird Leonarda 17 Mal schwanger
die letzten vier Kinder überleben laut
Leonardo mit Hilfe einer
örtlichen Zauberin na ja also eine gute
Hebamme und ein Krankenhaus mit voll
ausgestatteter Neonatologie werden
vermutlich effektiver gewesen aber ja
wir sind in der ersten Hälfte des 20
Jahrhunderts in Italien und nicht gerade
wohlhabenden Verhältnissen die vier
Überlebenden Kinder werden ihr ein und
alles in ihren Memoiren schreibt
Leonardo fast jede Nacht träumte ich von
den kleinen weißen Särgen die einer nach
dem anderen von der schwarzen Erde
verschluckt wurden deshalb habe ich
Magie studiert ich habe Bücher über
Handlesen Astrologie Beschwörungen
Verhexungen Spiritismus gelesen ich
wollte alles darüber lernen
Zaubersprüche um sie im neutralisieren
zu können
1930 zerstört ein Erdbeben das Haus der
Familie einem kleinen Dorf in der Nähe
von korrecio ein weiterer von zahllosen
Schicksalsschlägen allerdings nutzt
Leonarda diese Katastrophe um ihr
Schicksal zu wenden die Familie zieht
nach correcio um und erhält eine
Entschädigung und Leonarda die aus Angst
um ihre Kinder so viel über Zauberei und
war sargerei gelernt hat die gründet ihr
eigenes Start-up für handleserei
Astrologie und nicht mehr spezifizierte
Dienstleistungen
schön Umschreibung sie verkauft auch
Möbel Kleidung und Seife aus eigener
Herstellung
nix oh oh bis hierhin ist erstmal alles
vollkommen in Ordnung das Geschäft ist
zwar klein aber es läuft und hilft der
Familie über die Runden denn Raffael ist
Gehalt beim Amt ist man nicht gerade
üppig und dann 1939 bricht der Zweite
Weltkrieg aus Italien das vom
faschistischen Diktator Mussolini
regiert wird steht an der Seite
Deutschlands 1940 soll leonardas
Lieblingssohn Giuseppe der zu diesem
Zeitpunkt studiert ein berufen und an
die Front geschickt werden das ist
glaube ich für jede Mutter ein Schock
für Leonardo scheint es als wolle die
Vorhersehung sich nun ihr niest das Kind
holen das Kind dass sie am meisten liebt
und abgöttisch verehrt die Lösung liegt
auf der Hand ja zumindest aus
leonardascht sie muss dem Schicksal
einen Tausch anbieten ein anderer Mensch
muss sterben damit Giuseppe leben kann
und so plant sie auf wirklich kranke
Weise ein erstes Menschenopfer
[Musik]
fast tina hat noch nicht aufgegeben 70
Jahre ist sie alt und glaubt immer noch
an die Liebe mit 17 hat es nicht
geklappt warum sollte es nicht mit 70
klappen man ist nie zu alt für Labore
und tatsächlich stehen die Sterne
günstig das versichert ihr zumindest
ihre gute Freundin Leonarda und die
kennt sich mit sowas aus und sie hat
nicht nur in die Sterne geschaut sie hat
sogar schon einen passenden Mann
gefunden
dummerweise lebt er im heutigen Kroatien
heißt sie können sich nicht mal eben auf
einen Kaffee verabreden aber fast Tina
vertraut Leonarda die kennt ihn nämlich
persönlich und kann für ihn Bürgen und
ach er schreibt ihr sogar einen Brief
und lädt sie zu sich ein Leonarda wird
alles organisieren und Faustina händigt
ihr dankbar ihre gesamten Ersparnisse
aus
schließlich wird sie bald einen gut
situierten älteren Herren heiraten der
für ihren Lebensunterhalt aufkommt am
Tag vor der Abreise besucht sie Leonardo
noch einmal Leonarda rät ihr all ihren
Bekannten zu schreiben sobald sie in
Kroatien angekommen ist damit sich
niemand über ihr plötzliches
Verschwinden wundert da Faustina
Analphabetin ist schreibt Leonardo die
Briefe für sie dann reicht sie ein Glas
Wein und fossina trinkt auf das später
Liebesglück
natürlich gibt es keinen Mann in
Kroatien der auf fossina wartet
stattdessen gibt es vergifteten Wein und
eine Axt als das Gift wirkt und fustina
sich nicht mehr bewegen oder schreien
kann da schlägt Leonardo zu dreimal muss
sie mit dem Ball auf die wehrlose
einhacken bis sie endlich stirbt dann
zerteilt sie den Körper mit der Axt in
neun Stücke und dann beginnt der
wirklich makabere Teil lassen wir am
besten Leonarda selbst erzählen in ihren
Memoiren schreibt sie ich war auf die
Stücke in einen Bottich und fügte sieben
kilogramm@natron hinzu sie hatte ich
gekauft um Seife zu machen
anschließend rührte ich bis ich eine
dunkle dickflüssige Masse hatte die ich
in mehrere Eimer verteilte den Rest
lernte ich in eine Jauchegrube ich
wartete bis das Blut geronnen war dann
trocknete ich es im Ofen malte es und
vermischte es anschließend mit Mehl
Zucker Schokolade Milch Eiern und ein
bisschen Margarine daraus machte ich
jede Menge knusprige Kekse die ich an
meine Gäste und Besucher verteilte aber
Giuseppe und ich haben auch davon
gegessen
tja die seifenmacherin von correcio so
wird man sie später nennen ja die
plätzchenbäckerin von correcio hätte
auch gepasst irre oder was ich so krass
finde ist dass sie da einen Haufen Leute
unwissentlich zu Kannibalen gemacht hat
dann nimmst du von so einer freundlichen
Damen Keks an schwupps biste
Menschenfresser ein unschöner Gedanke
ein wirklich unschöner Gedanke ja wobei
ich mich frage also ich hoffe das klingt
jetzt nicht so despektierlich aber ich
meine das ist Italien das sind alles
Katholiken Blut und Kekse sind da
eigentlich nicht so ein diktiert die
gibt's jeden Sonntag nur halt nicht in
der Mitte
[Gelächter]
ja ja ja die heilige Kommunion Leib und
Blut Christi und so naja da begeben wir
uns auf wirklich ganz dünnes Eis Toni
vielleicht machen wir lieber mit
Leonardo da weiter ja gute Idee denn
Leonardo die macht auch weiter im
September 1940 verspricht sie eine
älteren und von Geld sorgen geplagten
Lehrerin sie können Ihr eine gut
bezahlte Stelle als Leiterin einer
Mädchenschule in einer anderen Stadt
vermitteln
auch die Lehrerin schreibt auf leonardas
geheißt Briefe an alle bekannten und
auch sie bekommt einen Wein und ihr ahnt
es auch sie endet in einer Keksdose
Toni ja sorry ich weiß das ist alles gar
nicht lustig aber dieser Story ist
absurd
Leonardo tötet sie mit der Axt verteilt
sie kocht sie und naja was soll ich
sagen etwas von ihr landet wirklich in
der Keksdose wobei wir nicht wissen ob
es eine Keksdose oder ein Keks Teller
oder was auch immer war aber das wird
doch langsam ein bisschen zu maghaber ja
wenn es Euch liebe Zuhörerinnen und
Zuhörer auch so geht dann schaltet ihr
jetzt besser schnell ab oder switcht in
irgendeine andere Folge dann es geht
tatsächlich noch fieser kurze Zeit
später sucht Virginia kacciopo bei
Leonardo nach Rat die sopransängerin war
einmal eine Berühmtheit in der Gegend
sie sagen Opern und das Publikum liebte
sie aber das liegt lange zurück
natürlich hat Leonardo gute Nachrichten
für Sie in Florenz gebe ist einen
reichen theateragenten der sie liebend
gern als seine rechte Hand anheuern
würde ja ihr ahnt worauf es hin gut
läuft Leonarda überzeugt die ahnungslose
Virginia alle Vorbereitungen zur Abreise
geheim zu halten ihr selbst deine
beträchtliche Geldsumme anzuvertrauen
und vor der Abreise auf einen letzten
Wein vorbeizukommen einen allerletzten
Wein sie stirbt unter leonardas axthemen
was dann folgt beschreibt Leonardo in
ihrer Autobiographie so sie endete im
Topf wie die anderen zwei auch aber ihr
Fleisch war fett und weiß als ich alles
aufgelöst hatte fügte ich eine Flasche
Parfüm hinzu und kochte sie lange Zeit
bis ich eine sehr cremige Seife erhalten
hatte ich verteilte Seifenstücke als
Geschenk an Nachbarn und Bekannte auch
die Süßigkeiten gelang besser die Frau
war wirklich süß
[Musik]
drei Frauen werden innerhalb kurzer Zeit
zum Opfer der seifmacherin von correcio
dann wird sie gefasst ihre Opfer sind
als vermisst gemeldet worden die
Schwester des letzten Opfers der
Opernsängerin weist zudem dass ihre
Schwester Virginia Leonardo chanculi vor
ihrem Verschwinden besuchen wollte und
es gibt Hinweise aus der Nachbarschaft
das Leonarda offenbar plötzlich zu Geld
zu viel Geld gekommen sei Klassiker
Verbrecher die geschnappt werden weil
sie ihr gestohlenes Geld verprassen auf
leonardas Konto werden größere
Zahlungseingänge der Frauen entdeckt
daraufhin wird Ihre Wohnung durchsucht
und man findet den Schmuck ihres letzten
Opfers
Leonardo chancelli wird verhaftet doch
die Polizei glaubt nicht dass sie die
alleinige Täterin ist jemand muss ihr
geholfen haben und vielleicht sogar der
Haupttäter gewesen sein niemals könnte
diese Mittelalter und harmlos wirkende
Frau in so kurzer Zeit wie sie behauptet
einen Menschen Zacken ja und sie
verhaften auch ihren Lieblingssohn
Giuseppe den sie ja eben vor dem Krieg
retten wollte und nun ins Gefängnis
gebracht hat und so gesteht sie alles in
aller Ausführlichkeit um abermals ihren
Sohn zu schützen doch die Ermittler
glauben ihr kein Wort bis okay das ist
dann jetzt wohl vielleicht der makabere
Höhepunkt des ganzen wenn es denn stimmt
wir haben mehrere Quellen dafür gefunden
aber keine die wirklich hundertprozentig
verlässlich ist
aber verdammtes passt einfach zu gut zu
der ganzen Geschichte
Leonardo chanculi lässt sich in eine
Leichenhalle führen und zerhackt vor den
Augen der staunenden Beamten eine nicht
identifizierte Leiche und zwar
fachgerecht und
kopfgerecht das alles in wenigen Minuten
auf das nun genauso passiert ist oder
nicht tatsache ist dass man ihr glaubt
Giuseppe kommt frei Leonarda sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft der Krieg verzögert
einen Prozess bis sie 1946 schließlich
zu 30 Jahren Haft und anschließenden
drei Jahren Unterbringung in der
Psychiatrie verurteilt wird also genau
das was die Wahrsagerin hier angekündigt
hatte genau das eigentlich hat alles
gestimmt das Leben voller Leiden das
Gefängnis dass sie ihre Kinder überleben
würde nicht alle aber 13 von 17 ja da
war schon einiges dran gut geraten und
ziemlich fies würde ich sagen aber wie
gesagt Leonarda glaubte an Magie und
Wahrsagerei okay Toni eine Sache wird
mir gerade noch im Kopf rum wenn sie
eigentlich mit einem Menschenopfer ihren
Giuseppe vor dem Tod retten wollte warum
hat sie dann drei Frauen umgebracht das
war sehr gute Frage das habe ich mich
auch gefragt
vielleicht wollte sie für ihre anderen
Kinder auch noch so eine ja Art naja
nennen wir es Versicherung abschließen
oder sie war der Meinung dass drei alte
Damen ein guter Tausch für das Leben
eines jungen Mannes sind man weiß es
nicht keine Ahnung wie das karamäßig
umgerechnet wird es gibt aber noch eine
dritte Erklärung nämlich dass Leonarda
schlicht und einfach gierig war oder es
nach dem geglückten ersten Mord wurde
sie selbst beharrte immer darauf dass
sie nur aus Liebe gemordet habe und so
schreibt sie es auch in ihrer
Autobiografie aber ich weiß nicht hier
hat zumindest eine Rolle gespielt sonst
hätte sie die Opfer wohl nicht auch noch
so schamlos ausgenommen und danach eben
mit ihrem neuen Wohlstand gebracht die
Prophezeiung dass sie nicht nur im
Gefängnis sondern auch in der
Psychiatrie landen würde erfüllte sich
übrigens nicht Leonard hat schon die
starb nachdem sie 24 ihre 30 Jahre Haft
abgesessen hatte
1970 in einem italienischen Gefängnis
das war echt ein
sehr sehr krasser Fall
ich würde sagen Mirko und damit beenden
wir auch die heutige Folge das war
wirklich mehr als genug ich will nicht
sagen das muss ich erstmal verdauen da
gebe ich dir auf jeden Fall recht wir
sind am Ende unserer heutigen Episode
und bedanken uns dass ihr mit dabei wart
die heutige Erzählung stammt unter
anderem von Beiträgen auf Museo
kriminologicalität all that's
interesting.com und Auszügen aus
leonardas Autobiographie Geständnisse
einer verbitterten Seele danke fürs
zuhören und nehmt euch keinen Keks macht
ein ganz großen bogenturm zumindest für
heute bis zum nächsten mal eure Toni und
euer Mirko ciao